in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to a very special
quarantine episode of the genius brain
podcast if you guys are actually
watching this on video this is actually
inside my living room because the office
that I was in decided to shut down due
to the whole Kovan situation I had about
two hours to pick up all my equipment
took it out grabbed about 60 pounds of
stuff and then reset it up back in here
and if you guys remember the last
podcast that I shot in there was with
Nick and Alex from the big mad podcast
so today we have a very special guest
and that will be my co-host for probably
the next six or seven episodes is Mary
song everybody hi everybody thank ya you
know what's interesting the last time we
were here and I told you about this we
had that whole episode where we're
talking about terrace house uh-huh so I
had a mutual friend who actually knew
about somebody that I hadn't was trying
to get on the show and that little boy
was that kid Yusuke so I was trying to
get him on the podcast and I was telling
her that literally about an hour before
he's about to shoot he decides that well
he basically gets cold feet and decides
to back out which number one I thought
was very unprofessional because we set
it up at a very specific time we set it
up ahead and there was supposed to be
another guest there and I pushed him in
and he decided to [ __ ] up my schedule so
I understand first but you know of
course [ __ ] you because it was weird
because so basically the conversation
went down where he was like prior before
I was gonna have him on he specifically
said and I quote I can even show you
guys the text message he goes hey man
you can go ahead and roast me all you
want
number one that's what he said I could
show you the text where he said I could
roast him and make fun of him on the
show and I was like number one I don't
do that on this undo his brain I don't
come on here and and verbally bash my
guests right so obviously he doesn't
know really who I am I think he just
kind of saw a clip of my personality but
before he comes on he watches the
episode where you and I were doing the
whole terrace house conversation which
it was I thought it was a fun
conversation there was no like I was
roasting anybody exact
I was simply talking about what we saw
on the show and whatever he saw from
that he got his feelings hurt yeah yeah
he was like I don't because I don't want
to be on your podcast because of the
things that you said about me I'll say
what did I say about you you [ __ ]
loser now I'm talking [ __ ] because I was
like at first I was kind of cool about
it right I was like yeah you know what
like I understand I mean he seems like a
little soft ass kid on them on the show
so obviously you know that's not a far
departure from who he was on this TV
show and that's what I really wanted to
ask him when he was coming on the
podcast what I wanted to ask him was do
you think that terrace house because
it's still a reality TV show gave him a
fair hand and who his real personality
is because you know no matter what in
reality TV people tend to or the way
that it's shot mm-hm they kind of had
their own agenda so I wanted to ask him
if like they felt that terrace house
kind of misrepresented how who he is as
a person
specifically when he was leading
catfished by himself you know at the
dinner and you know those dramas exactly
and basically if you guys haven't seen
that podcast what I was saying was that
he reminds me of a younger version of
myself and that he he'd like even you
said it's like oh if he got a little
more fit I didn't say he needed that
like he doesn't need to lose any weight
I think he's a very good-looking dude
he's very talented he has a nice sweet
personality it's just that he's he has
this tendency to to walk around with his
tail between his legs yeah I mean I
unless I really listened to him multiple
times to see like if we said something
wrong or like something that would hurt
I thank you we were just saying the
facts and if anything else it was all
about how much we adore him and we love
him we want to see him grow so I mean
maybe we just point out the things that
he really did hurt him like his weakness
which is exactly what we pointed out but
at the same time like I think that was
only 20% of the conversation not even a
toast yeah most the time I was
complimenting I know something you were
saying how much you love him and like I
was mentioning like how young he was and
like putting on the spot and I think he
just how he heard is the negative part
well here's the thing this and just to
bring up that video again if you guys
haven't seen that episode I talked about
how that that [ __ ] saying of nice
guys finish last mm-hmm it's [ __ ]
he's proving it right now he proved
everything I said in that [ __ ] video
it's
all these guys who see who say that
they're nice guys they're not really
that [ __ ] nice they're a little
egotistical like so what he wanted
obviously what the guy kind of wanted
and he could probably disagree if you
want to come on this podcast not be a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] about it is that
what really really is is that you know
these nice guys had this thing where
they say I'm a nice guy but that's
egotistical of you like it's all your
ego you're not that nice because you
didn't listen to the podcast and then
somebody said something that was maybe
truthful about how you were yeah and you
even said to come on to the space and
make fun of you which I wasn't going to
do that's words that's verbatim what he
said and then he [ __ ] out and he and
he acts as like a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
saying like oh I didn't like the stuff
that you said about me
it's like bro so you're not really a
nice guy you're actually proving what
I'm saying
it's like it's it's your ego and the way
you want it to come on this podcast and
you wanted me to suck your [ __ ] dick
and I wasn't going to do that the heck
is a form of expression do you think
that's a do you think the question that
you had for him about terrace house how
they represented him mm-hmm I think it's
true to who he is as a person is as raw
as it can get I think it's now it makes
me like to show you more because I
always have this thing in the back of my
mind where when I watch a reality TV
show I don't know if how much is
fabricated or not because I you know
I've done television stuff and I know
the behind that's behind the scenes
stuff that happens and as as real as it
can be there's a lot of stuff that's
fabricated all these shows like big what
not big house would you call that Big
Brother big house big house is a prison
Big Brother or even stuff like naked and
afraid there's a lot of stuff that's put
out there so people can you know enjoy
the show more yeah but for terrace house
I was wondering if they kind of made him
look kind of dweeby on purpose and I
wanted to see if you know if he felt
like it was a fair representation of who
he was and apparently it is it's like yo
you are that [ __ ] you just answer but
that have been coming yeah exactly in
the way he kind of responded was like
you could tell there was a little like
he was upset I was like you're upset
about what like what were you upset
about and on top of that - he wants to
be an entertainment it's like you want
to be an entertainment you're a [ __ ]
reality TV show star dude like that's
that's really what you're known for
right now are you still mad about
I'm not mad it's more like I kind of sat
with it and I was like oh like at first
cuz even I wrote to him after the whole
thing I said hey like I'm still rooting
for I think you're a nice guy like I'm
kind of confused about what I said but
yeah I understand man like a lot of
people don't know who I am and you know
I kind of have a lot of crass humor and
I look back at the video and I was like
oh man you're actually proving exactly
what people thought about you and the
stuff that I said about these fake nice
guys you're not that nice of a dude man
you're like this kid who you just want
praise you want people to say constantly
good things about you but you don't want
any criticism and once you get a little
criticism you start to break down and
crumble a little bit well guess what guy
you're an entertainment yeah you're in
[ __ ] entertainment what are popular
you get them more criticism y'all here's
exactly what did you expect
and especially you're gonna you're gonna
back out on the last hour when I
replaced you with another guest like he
added more work for me over something as
over nothing so what I'm thinking is
like he didn't even hear the whole
podcast he heard a couple of things and
then he got in his feelings and he
gotten really [ __ ] upset and he
[ __ ] up my schedule if anything else
you've probably heard it from someone
else I doubt that he even listened to
himself it was just that people were
commenting him something maybe either
way he's a little [ __ ] [ __ ] so it is
who he is it's like [ __ ] bummer how it
ended up yeah and the weird thing was
it's like he said roast me that was the
weird part it's like bro I'm not gonna
have you come on the show I'm gonna make
fun of you I just doesn't know what that
means
I mean his first language after all he's
been here for a while he's English is
perfectly fine so you're a little [ __ ]
anyways we're gonna move on from that
yeah he had to let it out well I wanted
to put him on blast real quick just
because you know it was just it was dumb
it was just really stupid [ __ ] loser
alrighty anyways on anyways so we we
went on I went on Twitter and I asked
people to kind of ask questions that
they want to ask you to can do in Dubin
beause actually decide to ask this
question those high those I love both
shout out to bows by the way
what's David's worst habit around the
house I bet you would've loved that
hold on the worst I had to pick one you
have to pick one what's my worst habit
your worst habit is I oh you're so gonna
disagree with me but let me just do
that's not around the house it's just
our personalities clashing oh no I
wasn't even thinking about that
just around there's that many there's
that many it has to do a lot with the
bathroom and the kitchen okay I already
know right off the bat what she's gonna
talk about the bathroom stuff she hates
it when I leave the toilet seat up it is
disgusting it is inappropriate why is it
here's the thing this is why it's
disgusting ladies we sit down ray we pee
it doesn't go anywhere but inside a
toilet guys on the other hand I didn't
know that you cannot control where it
splatters so when you put the toilet
seat up and you pee you have the
remainings on the rim and I have to see
that before I put the toilet seat down
and can I put the toy seat down oh I
have to go and clean it because it
bothers me because how dirty that's a
personal thing it's not a personal thing
you got to clean up yourself right like
if it'll splatter you have the toilet
paper for a reason to clean and it'll
splatter here and there every now and
then if it does think you should clean
up yourself because it's your own crap
sometime but but a sometimes I'm just
answering the question you know you know
you forget okay
so yeah you could forget sure it's a
middle-of-the-night min of the night I
have to go to the bathroom too now I
have to be extra cautious whether or not
the toilet seat is down because if not I
would have to sit on your pee stain and
inside the toilet well I don't here's
here's mine but here's my argument about
it right so when I have to use the
bathroom right I have to lift and put it
down all the time now you only have to
do have to work actually no we decided
that we're gonna put everything down so
we both do the work and put it up and
down so technically no we do the same
amount of work
well now we do but you don't want to do
that so you lit it up it's not just
telling you to do it every time I just
and you know that turns into nagging for
you but I can't help it I try to it's
not hot and I'm provides but compromise
no that's the result he says no no
exactly because I can disagree with you
here's the problem okay
and I told you about this too it's that
I told you for 30 years I've been doing
the same thing over and over and over
again right in her household there's
three men and there's one woman and my
mom she doesn't agree about the toilet
seat thing either she doesn't care okay
right so when somebody has a habit for
30 years right before they decide to
live with somebody right it's gonna be a
hard habit to break so what I asked for
is a grace period right it's gonna take
some time I've been getting better every
every time when we first started it was
very hard for me and I wasn't doing it
on purpose
it was just I couldn't remember because
it just it's not a habit that's built
inside me mm-hmm and you know other
girls that I've dated David also didn't
care as much as you you care a lot
you're the first person that I've been
with that scares this much I kid you not
it's actually one of my pet peeves is
that I didn't even know because I did
because my dad always put the toy seat
exact because he had a household of two
women versus exactly so I never thought
that would be an issue so I never knew
that was gonna be a pet peeve until I
saw her yeah my only problem was is that
you you always said you said the word
always constantly and you almost took it
as if I was doing it on purpose and then
I told you that I wasn't doing it on
purpose
it's just that night just it was not a
habit and that it's going to take time I
just need that grace period yeah and now
I do it about I sail about 65% the time
I have the other 35% I I miss which is
fine I mean I don't get mad at you right
I just tell you it was a long journey
though you have to get be flipping mad
you used to it like she would get so mad
like I would be laying in bed and she
would come at me as if I murdered one of
them she was like I can't believe you
know how important this is to me I'm
like what happened what did I do
6:00 a.m. in the morning this is what
I'm being at okay like I said it was my
pet peeve right and the reason why I
would get agitated is because you
wouldn't
except you would try to go against it be
like I don't understand I have to do all
the work I have to do out of work but
you wouldn't come together with me and
compromise we did have the toilet both
things that came around after the fact
of course because I didn't agree that's
why I was mad but you can't be mad at me
for not agreeing with something because
because prior to that because you
wouldn't have a conversation with me I
would ask you put the toilet seat down
and you would just say no you would just
disagree because exactly because so that
belong to disagree you're allowed to
disagree right and I'm allowed to be
agitated no you know you're not allowed
to be agitated if somebody disagrees
with you that's where I disagree wrong I
didn't get agitated because you
disagreed with me I got agitated because
the toilet seat was up all the time and
you wouldn't compromise I would the
compromise was the both seat thing that
was after the fact exact cuz I disagreed
that's what I'm saying I wasn't going to
do it because we didn't have a
compromise at that point that's exactly
what I'm saying
and I was agitated us that's why what
you shouldn't be agitated what I'm
saying because I'm coming from my point
of view and you're coming from yours yes
and I asked a lot of people too about
this I was like why do you why do your
why do your guy put the toilet seat down
because because of the girl just because
because for that girl I'm like oh that's
really nice that's cool I'm not like
that thing I know is that I'm somebody
who needs to you need to explain the tea
and then what I understand it then I
move on once you get sick of that nag
you up do it no we found a compromise
because I don't like that thing where
this see I don't like that a lot
especially in a lot of guys who are in
relationship they go I just do it just
because like I'll do it just because -
but I need somebody to explain it it's
the same way when I grew up as a kid
right my parents would tell me to do
stuff without explaining things and I
used to piss me off I hate that [ __ ]
especially when it's a command I don't
like being commanded so for example for
you when you and I I know you don't like
to being commanded you don't like to be
commanded you don't like to be asked
it's very hard to talk yeah there's
nothing I don't like to be asked I like
things to be explained this podcast is
brought to you by purple my friends the
only mattress that I let touch this body
because sleep is important and without
sleep I am nothing when you sleep while
you're calm
two functions are through the roof
science baby ever since I've had a
purple mattress I have been able to
argue every point with my fiance because
I can remember every little detail as
she doesn't because my sleep is so damn
good
the purple mattress will feel different
because it is different from your
typical mattress it's breathable it
stays cool it's firm and plush at the
same time it's just right a hundred
night a risk-free trial backed by a ten
year warranty free shipping and returns
you're going to love purple and right
now my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site Y just text
brain to eight four - eight eight eight
the only way to get this free pillow is
to Tex brain - eight four - eight eight
eight that's B R a I n - eight four
eight eight eight message and data rates
may apply so and like I said like I'm
telling you right now the source is
because going up with parents who just
told me what to do all the time and I
used to get my ass beat if I would ask
questions I hate that habit so if I'm
asking a question or if I don't know and
I'm inquisitive about things sometimes
when I disagree or I ask questions you
think that I'm attacking you or you
think that I don't think what you're
saying is dumb it's only sounds dumb at
the moment because nobody's explained it
to me so I need you to explain so you
think that it is right so so if you
explain it right I'm I still disagree
with you but that's what conversation
comes out of but that conversation parts
the part where you get agitated yeah
because you disagree from the start
rather than because I already have my
opinion and you think it's dumb to you
just admit it but in the disagreement
it's a lot for me to think it's dumb but
you should still explain it like I'm not
going oh I will explain it I can't until
it is done with rage with rage yes
because you are very hard to communicate
with because you already have an opinion
which is dumb and it's hard to overcome
that because you already have it set
that's why it's hard to communicate and
without any emotion because you will
explain your side so thoroughly that
it's like where is the whole them
halfway for me to explain this because
you just shoved everything in my face
now I mean yeah yeah go ahead
at that point that's where you should
come in with your points that's that's
what I do it takes and then he said and
then when you said we need to put both
the toilet seats down I had I couldn't
really say anything I still don't like
it he didn't like I still didn't like it
but I had no come back cuz you were
right and so now at that point it was
just for me to build that habit I
remember you didn't like that you're
like no that's so much work exactly you
took a while but I'm like it makes sense
yeah but then you you never set that you
never say you are right you don't see me
to say why it takes you some time
sometimes days weeks months for you to
realize what I said is actually right I
never hear it and you disagree at the
beginning so I never know what the
conclusion is it's just later on your
action shows oh okay he look anything
let me tell you something here all right
actions speak louder than words let me
drop this mic real quick actions speak
louder than words
what's good you want the words or you
want the action you choose one no you
don't want the words I went away because
the words don't gonna have to do the
action then you don't do the action
something I do the action so let me
choose which one you want you want words
or actions man God I take his words
seriously
oops sorry I gotta stop touching but yes
not pounding why are you pounding the
table so hard a lot of emotion cuz now
you see this mouths it's being it's
right here do you see that rage that you
have it's all that piling up of you not
understanding I understand I need a lot
of patience for it'll for you to
understand where I am coming from
exactly because you do a lot of it just
because stuff just because it's like
because because I'm a girl and I you
should list I don't like that stuff I
like things explained so girls have to
do that I don't like that girls have to
Pete
I can't speeding up honey and and I am
when I pee I have to do you see why when
I explain my side it's I can explain it
because there's a logical thought to it
you know I have a wait hold on hold on
hold on this whole conversation is
saying that my side is not logical no
that's not see you just did it right now
I'm glad it's recorded no no I said that
on purpose because you just said I'm not
saying that your size side isn't logical
that's not what I said uh-huh I'm saying
I need a logical thought process rather
than rather
you just saying just because so I'm not
saying that your sight isn't logical
what I'm saying is that you didn't
explain it from the get-go I did I
didn't say an explanation is an
explanation isn't because I'm a girl and
I'm gonna fall through that doesn't
explain it thoroughly you have to think
about the thought process that's what I
mean by explain things thoroughly that's
not that's not enough though with that
so the fact I'm gonna fall through no
because that doesn't make sense because
all you can do is put the seat down do
you see what I'm saying so there's this
business solution to your problem so the
the do you see I'm saying just like my
solution is just to lift the seat up
uh-huh so it's even now all it is is
even but when you said mm-hmm right the
whole dirty thing and so what we can do
is just put both the seats down that's
the compromise I didn't want to do it
but you were still right and so that's
why we could change yeah thank you for
telling me that I am right but what's
the difference if I just do it if you
just do it do what so you want me to be
like you're right yeah it would just be
like I hate this I hate this but I'll
still do it anyways and I just start
doing it you could just you can say that
- I did say that no you said I hate and
it's like that doesn't make sense it I
didn't say the doubles toilet seat thing
that makes sense I just had just a lot
of work you were against it but I didn't
say it didn't make sense though what did
you say I said I hate it this is a lot
of work yeah so yeah I started doing it
see that's the thing though you said I
hate it it's a lot of work you didn't
say but I'll do it I did that's why I
started doing it but so vows this is
this is this is what it is his worst
what is it with uh what's the question
it is what's Dave his worst habit around
the house it's putting the toilet seat
well let me tell you what your worst
habit is okay okay you my dear are
germaphobe and you're you you are a
picky like a mofo hey people come in
here and they say it's clean for a read
the the times that you say that is
filthy and dirty people come in here
they go this is really really clean
because I clean it up I mean no it's
because no I'm talking about the times
where you think it's filthy nobody
thinks it's filthy
and we talked about this - you admitted
that you have a very very high
expectation of what clean is I am I am
very OCD because especially now because
I'm allergic to dust you see me huh no
that's actually facts she actually had
an
test and she's allergic to everything
everything in the environment apparently
I'm allergic to especially dust like if
you blow in her face her face will turn
out I never done this before by recently
since last year I've been taking allergy
medicine every day morning day and night
and it's because of the dust because
prior to this apartment we lived in in
Glendale and another apartment where it
was close to the city and I've never
lived that close like in the city before
and the next thing I know is that I'm
just red and swollen up for no reason
so I took allergy tests and finding out
maybe it's food I hope it's not food
food no I'm perfectly fine with food
it's the environment it just is around
me I will swell up
I was also allergic to dust so Abe is my
manager he's allergic to dust and plants
this fulls meant to die yeah he's
allergic to play there's a lot of
Platinum's Bissell is two steps away
from exploding into a million pieces but
he has so many plans and is right
exactly he took them all out so he's
actually allergic to plants isn't that
[ __ ] crazy wait how does that work I
don't know but he also continually broke
out in hives so when she was
specifically when she worked at a
different company before it was a
high-stress job and so well her hives
actually comes out obviously when it's
super dirty and also because of stress
when you stress out your hives come out
like a ridiculous amount yeah I had
hives and eczema which was really weird
too because I've never had eczema before
and in my hands was just so dry and so
bad stress yeah that was stress so yeah
do do that I gotta make sure that I'm
extra clean and oh by the way last year
everybody got the flu which we don't
know what if it's or Corona Corona I was
the only one who didn't get it because I
kept myself very clean which is by
washing your hands everything first of
all that's already false so let me
explain why see this guy loves to debate
why am i living with it there was the
holiday party mm-hmm right and it wasn't
just me it was it was
feels like 30 people I got yeah that's
true all right
another four now is there - yeah but you
were there for a shorter time and I ate
a lot of food there I ate a lot of big
much well girl you didn't you a copy
really you are twice as large as those
mines what I mean so then apparently
everybody in that room was filthy no but
we were all hugging each other touching
each other and then less thing you know
boom and first and second of all just to
bring up my point she hates hugging she
doesn't like that's so hug she doesn't
like random interaction with excuse me
she can't touch whale attraction
correction it's not that I don't like
hugging I do like hugging you're just
good at it leave me I'm good at visit
you you like you're very natural my dear
you don't like hugging I like hugging I
like to be hot sometimes I want to watch
you hug somebody it's almost as if
somebody has a gun to your head
it's like deep it's like you're just
like watching a robot come to life I
don't know what I don't know I'm not
used to it but I love it I love when
someone hugs me I you don't look like it
it looks like their body is covered in
seams
I'm not I'm not comfortable with it but
I didn't mean it wasn't me that I don't
like it I don't like that my case in
point is that I hug literally a
gajillion people that day and you could
have washed your hands when you came
back by you decide not to
I showered when I came back I shower
every night you know that come on to
your false true or false
did I shower you do shower bulb in your
face baby shower right away you have to
wash your hands right away okay here
here's the thing guys when you guys go
out and you come back home what's the
first thing you should do most people I
guarantee you right now and I'd be
surprised and don't [ __ ] lie in the
comments you sons of [ __ ] how many of
you out there real talk if your hands
aren't dirty they don't smell they don't
have anything sticky on it or anything
else if you just went outside real quick
real quick okay don't take that real
quick we're not talking about real yeah
but I wash my hands over there after I
was done eating because I grabbed all
that [ __ ] I had like sauce on my hands
now I feel I've seen you not on your
hand when you go out and your hands are
perfectly clean generally clean how many
of you the first thing that you do when
you walk into question is very bias
there is very bias it's not by these are
facts I'm saying I don't wash my hand if
it's clean no that's not
because we've gone out before and you
had burgers you used your hands oils
everywhere use the napkin to wipe down
your hands that's very true but you
didn't go and wash your hands with so
many came home you lie down on so if I
play with your phone and turn on the TV
these are mad facts right now did you go
wash your hands
I cleaned it with the napkin that's it I
clean it with the napkin all right
there was no burger grease on it all
right brother
burger grease right now is facts that
you're adding all right let me tell you
something God has blessed me I'm so sure
I'm so pure when I touch a burger the
burger just gets that as tight that's
who I am this is crazy talk this is how
we talk you guys I'm trying to convince
him to wash his hands and he says
nonsense I want to wrap up this question
I'm a germaphobic and you like to put
the toilet seat up this is a little hard
we when we first here's the thing I've
never lived with the girl and Muriel has
never lived with the boy before we
actually out of you know I've had a
handful of serious relationships other
than like girls that I've dated clearly
not serious enough to live with that oh
absolutely not
Imperator well that was it that was it
that was a big thing though where you
know what I kind of feel bad when I
think about this now is that when I was
with this girl uh-huh
I never introduced her to my really
close friends and I and I really
genuinely thought that I that I cared
for her and even you know borderline
love right and when I look back on it I
don't know why I never introduced them
to her like I know there wasn't an
opportunity to do it because we were all
so busy working but there are people if
I really did care about her I would have
taken the time and she lived we were
long distance I would have taken the
time when she was here to be like hey
man I want you guys to meet my new
girlfriend
and I never did that and I realize
together and not even that long probably
like six seven months maybe that's the
six seven months you met you met Bart
geo and all them yeah and you know what
the interesting thing is well I met them
by a
because he forgot you had yeah well
scheduling was different to you also
lived on the west side of LA and then
you know our work schedules never really
matched up yeah and so like with her I
remember the first time as she met Bart
geo and them and I didn't even introduce
her as my girlfriend I didn't even think
about that Wow but we went to go eat
Korean barbeque and she was sitting
there the whole time we were eating
chatting up having a good conversation
in bed she was hurt and I didn't realize
that I was like yeah cool cool cool on
the next day oh ah I say she was hurt
but she never vocalized it mm-hmm
um but the next day I was like amen like
what you guys think about my girlfriend
they're like da gávea no she was your
girlfriend I was like what what do you
mean he's like you didn't introduce her
as your girlfriend so once you say
something I was like oh [ __ ] did I not
say she was my girlfriend it's so
insensitive
but I would I didn't even think about
that [ __ ] I genuinely didn't think I
didn't think about it though like I
didn't think that I didn't do that I
didn't do it like it was obvious that he
was she was your girl I felt like I told
him about her before or something and
you know I'm just kind of going about my
thing and I didn't realize at that
moment that number one I hadn't
introduced them to her cuz it was just a
Korean barbecue dinner date that we
always do and she was there and then
number two I only realized after the
fact they mentioned it so you never
talked to them about her I was like he
should have you probably know I
mentioned her but then they never that
was the first time that they I should I
don't know her name then nation maybe I
mentioned the girl that I was dating but
she was my girlfriend and mind you like
those were straight up - yeah we were
dating for at that point at least like a
couple of months yeah and so yeah I kind
of now think about it kind of feel
really bad about that moment but I she
never actually vocalized that her
feelings were hurt because of that but
when I look back on it now she was
probably really hurt about that I had a
lot of very classy guys I think that's
why I like classy but these guys were
like more gentleman I mean like the
children children chivalrous a
chivalrous shivudu see what is this
Steve it is a guy
who you know live with women or lived
with female siblings where they it was
kind of obvious for them like to do
those kind of stuff because they lived
or they were I don't know if that
chivalry though I think that's just that
was one of the things yeah I think the
toilet seat down isn't chivalrous I
think that is just a rule that women
made that guys came with it though
that's what I'm saying yeah like
chivalry to me is more like you know
being a gentleman opening the door or
something like that yeah it's so funny
because at work I'm so used to opening a
door for everyone so when I hang out
with my new friends I hope in the door
for them they're like come on you gotta
let the man do this one so like oh yeah
I forgot sorry I'm so used to doing this
myself
hey she don't open my doors though I
always be opening doors in this
relationship I'm always behind you I'm
in front of you table I know I open the
doors oh and then way I'm always behind
exactly what are you talking about never
opened you've changed so much like
before you used to be always behind me
super slow cuz I was hundred and seventy
pounds not my fault you'll understand
that wait okay I've been walking the
same speed since day one understand do
you understand what what he does to your
body at almost 300 pounds do you
understand that you weren't walking and
normal speed when you were telling me
that I'm walking too close I tell you
right now I walk really fast I don't
think that I walk in a normal speed now
I do art oh you work fat I walk fast now
right so it's it's different so back
then when I was really fat you were
working very slow no I was walking at a
normal the average one because now
you're working faster than me so that's
why you don't make any damn sense at all
cuz this girl right now she will bike
she will bike from here to Sacramento
like 500 miles like it's nothing right
but you had this girl walk up this a
slight slant I'm talking I'm talking
about maybe 12 degree slant right you
see her face she is huffing and puffing
like crazy it's the altitude okay I
can't stand the a feet altitude of South
Pasadena you get the hell out of here
right now are you talking about the
altitude from one point to another point
okay
Viking II go straight everything else
you have to walk oh so in South Pasadena
you guys know in order for me to lose
all this weight I decide I walk about
you know three to four miles I used to
do that [ __ ] every day recently because
of kickboxing nicely busted my foot so
today was probably the first time that
actually walked the really really long
distance it's been a month I spent about
a month yeah
yes it was pretty long and um it still
hurt it hurt actually pretty bad but I
had to because I can't even kick box I
can't really get into a boxing stance
and the only thing I could really do is
do the Instagram push-up challenge yeah
stop do it abso-fucking-lutely not come
on you always do the ab roller
okay that's different though I did I got
text 18 times just do I want I can't do
a hundred and eighty push you just said
to do all of them just do is I know
[ __ ] like that alright what's up my
Tamia I do it all the way can I say one
more thing that is a weird habit of
yours what it's it's been recent that I
see it you leave use cups everywhere and
you get a new one you know what girl is
how much you use you leave the whole
thing there and get a new cup and then
wraps up this episode you spray a
podcast that's why come on you know
what's interesting about that too
actually yeah I didn't notice that
and I started pissing myself off because
that actually that's actually one of my
pet peeves so when I started yourself
when I started doing I was like who's
cups are these it's like these are my
cups look what the [ __ ] am i doing and
you know what it is is because I'm
always here now and so I don't I don't
know what I'm grabbing a cup or not I
don't know whose it is why don't you
just hold on to that one cup well cuz I
leave it and I go back and I'm like is
this Muriel's I was like oh this
situation we should be sharing our stuff
it's not like it's never my said Mike
well now that I know but I was getting
annoyed at myself I'm like why don't I
keep on grabbing these new [ __ ] cups
and just because like I don't know whose
cups these are no we know it's just mine
so I'm trying to slow that down today
did you notice only two cups you are not
home all day today
case in point baby oh it's just some
weird habit it's not it's not as bad for
me with the toilet seat I think the
toilet see is a pet peeve for me because
I'm a germaphobic and when I see it all
the pee stains everywhere and it's not
clean chuckles my guys with the pee
stains man
it's disgusting
and it splatters house side to like on
the floor around the toilet that's where
it ticks me off and like why am i have
to clean your crap because I'm a bad guy
baby you don't have a diaper listen I'm
a tall guy and sell the water hadn't
actually you know what I'm a tall guy
with a large penis so I best I have no
excuse you also have two big hands so
why don't you wipe it down yourself
cracker you gotta be disrespectful as
podcast I'll try and wipe it down but
you do have thank you very very very
high standard of what clean is and you
have to understand that out of any men
you've been to your homegirls spots
where the guys live and you know how
[ __ ] filthy men are so you have to
admit I am extremely clean compared to
most dudes you know for you know for a
fact you think of anyone who's you
recently not that long ago went to one
of your friends boyfriends and you saw
that's one
yeah but just to put out that point his
job requires him to work a lot my job
requires me to work a lot as well and my
place never looks like that thank God
exactly I have to say you're not you're
not dirty and I'm not that messy
you're not that messy either you just
have certain like no it's fine actually
you're normal I'm just extreme is the
case I'm actually I'm actually really
clean your extreme yeah I'm extreme
there's net out of all the women that
I've dated I've been with the the
consistent thing that they've said is
that I'm a really really really clean
guy I thought you were - I am like just
not as clean as you correct that's why
you trippin is what I'm saying I don't
trip it's working if my feet bottom
amount bare feet
they got a little dust on this all dusty
body a different color different palette
then that means it's dirty if there are
fingerprints on the fridge that means
it's dirty but it's fine because I'm
going with but it's my honey because I
don't you know because I know that I'm
extreme I clean it myself I ask you to
clean it I ask you to clean after
yourself when you do a crazy cooking
session because that's a lot of work and
I didn't ask you let me tell you this we
actually got into an argument not too
long ago and this one was the funniest
harder than ever and I told this to a
lot of different home girls and they
didn't understand this your home girls
are different from my home girls
okay well we'll tell this too it will
ask the audience then also the audience
is your fan so acknowledge I can't
always disagree with me so it's okay
okay so she got mad at me because of the
way that I respond to her when she asks
a favor so when she asks something right
so for example she'll be like throw away
the trash I go sure she gets upset
she'll be like do this with Matt go yep
I don't say throw away the trash I ask
you very nicely well of course it
doesn't matter either way I say yes and
then what do I do
do I do it or do I not do we converse
okay I think that's the problem is
because you're not telling my point of
view okay okay okay your point of view
first there is a request when there is a
request that I need someone else to do I
think about how they want to hear for me
because I know David doesn't like to be
come in demand exactly because it's a
favor when you ask for favors you have
to ask nicely exactly so when I say when
I want him to take that take out the
trash I don't say hey take out the trash
no you don't that's ever said that you
can rewind this you'll hear it you said
that's that's what you said I said that
how you demanded out of me no you said
take out the trash no I'm not saying
that's a problem though even if you said
it like that it's not a problem it is a
problem because you don't like to be
demanded I should make sure that I say
in a way where you could hear me but hey
if you said this hey can you take out
the trash fine mm-hmm
said like this take out the trash mm-hmm
that's different mm-hmm right hey can
you you don't have to go
hey okay first of all I don't do that to
you that's you exactly that's just to
show how nice I asked you think she
asked nice you should see how nice she's
going know what I asked when I asked I'm
like this hello can you please take up
this dinky twist please because each
males by the way I always take out the
trash ain't never take out the trash
once their life she don't know where the
garbage can is but now the time where
you didn't know where the dishwasher
soap was so this podcast thank you guys
for coming out to listen but you know
was she saying that she asked really
nicely which I understand because when
you ask a favor from somebody especially
in this household you should ask nicely
when I respond she doesn't she's not
happy with my response my response is
got it and then I do it what's the
problem your respond yep got it I asked
him three seconds later sure
what's that problem it still doesn't
make sense so you know what the three
seconds later I'll bring up the specific
example she's talking about right now
specific so there's this beautiful just
desk that I had shoutouts to my old desk
I miss you very much
we had great times together the way that
you were shaped it wasn't it wasn't like
a normal square desk it was like some
rock cut wood and I liked the fact that
you were super wrong with it I miss you
very much I wrote a lot of sketches with
you hold on a second let me just I know
exactly where it is right now yeah shout
out to the to the couple that bought it
from me I hope you guys take care of
Esmeralda very well she hey stop
laughing this is serious thank you for
taking Kass mirela
very well she was so she was important
man her curves her shapes
she she had two women in the house
Esmerelda's a man actually the way the
shape of his legs and penis was
fantastic unlike anyways so she was
asking me to move things out the way
because these dudes were gonna come over
and they were going to pick up the desk
right and she goes hey can you move the
toosh so we have these two short shoe
storage things up on the stairs and I
have to move them out the way first so
they could bring out the desk so she
goes can you do that I pause for three
seconds I go got it and she makes sure
sure whatever I hope she would the
reason why she was upset was because
that three-second pause do you know what
I was doing in the three seconds
I was thinking thinking oh there's a
buffering now uh listen you talk like no
first of all don't ever call me mm okay
second of all second of all I was
thinking about where I should place the
shoe thing to get it out the way to
require less work because my foot was
busted so I wasn't thinking about oh she
asked me this favor
I wasn't thinking like oh she's being
annoying I was thinking okay how am I
gonna do this and I said sure
and what did I do did I complain about
it it's funny I want to yes or no right
yeah no no you didn't do that perfectly
did I do it my dear did I did I do sit
with a broken foot did I Do's it really
well tell me right now
you did fine thank you it's funny how
you've brought up the example of the
trash but then you ended up with the
specific example that you recall what
treasure is all gonna be nothing to do
with the trash example I'm only talking
about the trash example what about the
trash example I asked you honey can you
take out the trash please and then you
had pauses to us and be like sure and
it's not three seconds though the trash
thing was never three seconds those are
lies lies pure lies it's like this can
you take out the trash I go got it
one second boom in your face it has
never been three seconds are you lying
right now before God this is why it's so
hard to have a conversation with this
man when you talk to I need a workout
daily to let the stress out I'm talking
to a wall that has a mouth amano ears I
do I listen I listen to everything that
you say but I'd be breaking
get down dude yeah cuz you're so
stubborn
you sure cuz right now and tell me okay
well this wraps up this episode of
genius proportions alright moving on
okay see what I mean for you what we
just said we have never lived with the
opposite sex before right because I
noticed too that when you talk to your
friends you talk good way differently
than you talk to me especially when it
comes the same when it comes to
disagreements you're okay when they
disagree with you absolutely but when I
disagree with you know it's a challenge
it's it's terrifying
it's it's mortifying and the way that
you respond to me I'm a verbal
affirmation person as you know I just
sing a song right now it's about verbal
affirmation that's his verbal after
mission as it gets that's not answering
me though that's that's different and
hearing very emotionless answers for me
when I try really hard and I know it's
like emotions how can you how can I add
emotion to pick up a trash oh yes i'ma
take out the trash what do you want from
me just just a normal yes look at this
trash is it innate what did you say my
trash collections company I would prefer
that did you think I'm a boy oh boy who
has nothing but that's just the case
because I strophe I don't have that
emotional attachment to them as what I
have with you you know everything's
extreme as you know we've been together
for a quieter so extreme it's so hard to
but you're also you know that for a fact
that you're extreme with me too in what
ways explain it to me right now
I can't I can't say this in public but
it's just emotion you you say anything
in public my dear
you know crook yeah and there's one
thing the one problem that I have is
that I have horrible memory so uh okay
she I know what she's I know what she's
talking about
so he's about to get real here so the
way that Muriel and I grew up is very
different the way that we grew up in our
household there's two things that
happens so there's two sides of this
coin when you love extreme you also get
angry in extreme ways too and I have
expressed myself when I get angry I get
really mad and the reason why is because
also Muriel has never she's an only
child she has never dealt with conflict
resolution in a way that I think that
most people learn how to deal with
siblings or people that you live with so
for example this is a quick story all
actually we let's not be specific about
this because there's too many of
instances like this well Hulk when I go
when I get mad and I ask for space
I need Scott I need space like that's
that's actually something I learned from
anger management it's like ask for space
when you're really upset and you need to
calm down right problem with Herman we
first started dating is that she even
openly admitted I have in this one time
she would like push my buttons on
purpose and I hated that [ __ ] and when I
would ask for space it was because I
used to have a lot of anger problems we
even had this moment once where there
was only one moment in my life with
Muriel that I actually almost broke up
with her and it's because I yelled at
her so [ __ ] loud I was like an inch
away from her face and I was like
slightly sick and phlegm flew out and
hit her face as I was you know it's not
my face it was my shoulder right that
was so disgusting I've never had
someone's phlegm on my body yeah and I
and number one after this and we were on
our way to okay and I went on the way
there I'm ironic I literally told her
that after this after we're done going
this wedding we're gonna break up and
actually did I did no I said that you
said that you were you were on the verge
of it but you didn't say they were gonna
break up all right well two different
accounts of the story yeah because
because we promised to each other that
we would never use our
and this it was gonna happen maybe I
said that we were probably gonna break
up I say you said that you wanted to
yeah and the reason why is because she
used to do this thing where if I ask
somebody to stop and I'm getting mad and
I start boiling
I just need silence because I don't want
to get angry but for her she this is
this is by the way by the way this is
past Mariel this is not Mariel now she
would do this thing question this is
past David yeah she would push my
buttons really hard and if I if I say
hey I'm getting mad I need I need you to
stop she wouldn't stop and then he would
just build build build and I just yelled
at her and at that moment when I was
yelling at her but the peak of my anger
I look back and I was like hey I don't
like this and what I told her verbatim
and so what I said was like I I went
through a lot of anger managed
management to learn how to not be this
person and if I'm with you and you make
me into a worse person than I can't be
with you that's verbatim what I said
mm-hmm it's because I didn't like the
person that I was going to become and I
said I when I'm with you and you do this
to me I become somebody that I don't
want to be mm-hmm so that's why mm-hmm
and I have to say though yeah I learned
a lot through those kind of moments me
too a lot and then and it's true I
didn't it's funny because I don't think
to anyone I really do that like what
hope them yeah you know I mean I think
that's why I don't fight really with
friends because I know my boundaries
yeah you don't care enough it's like
yeah whatever you belong uh I just I
maybe it's a it's a thing it's a girl
thing where we feel the vibe is like we
don't need a crosstown line unless we
want yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean like we
know where it went not to cross a line
and when it comes to you there is no
line right you just cross it we have to
cross it if we don't then we're friends
yeah I mean I think that's the hard part
about relationships I don't know if
people agree or disagree
at this point but it's like it's because
our emotions are so sensitive you know
like that's why I mean have you ever
been angry to your friends like that
yeah but I [ __ ] them up though that's
different it's not that kind they
weren't that close
you know like your close friends no no
never you would never do that but with
me I'm pretty sure we have multiple of
those too and another thing is that you
didn't know that that during that fight
you found out that I call this Tom my my
boyfriend my other boyfriend that comes
in once every month to all the female
unfortunately and there's something
called pre Tom where they are out of the
month time of the month there's a pre
time where we have side effects where we
become very sensitive very oh I just
remember this so check this out the
reason why I was also really really
upset with her is because I actually
asked her I said hey when you aren't
pretty top more tom is around I just
need you to tell me and admit that the
reason why you're agitated is because of
this but at the time you would deny it
you denied you're like no you're just
being an [ __ ] and I'm like what what
what do you want I'm sane and asked what
not you didn't say that you didn't say
that but you're basically saying I was
being an [ __ ] right and you didn't
say the word [ __ ] but it's like what
the like what do you want like that's
like that's the thing I didn't a prior
to you my emotions were never that
extreme especially pre Tom like I never
had that kind of emotion so it it didn't
make sense to me that it's because of
that and my emotions are like this to
all the guys out there you know exactly
what I'm talking about
that said he also realized oh this is
how it is like during pre Thompson oh
I've been realizing that you wouldn't
admit it so the only thing that you
would admit at the time you want to be
any nicer though Oh a hundred percent
don't worry my dear a hundred percent if
he told me at the time if you would have
just admitted that right because because
you said because I didn't know yeah
because you wouldn't admit that solution
was out there out the window so I'm like
oh so I'm I'm so we're just not made for
each other that's what I thought because
you would not admit cuz you were like
I'm not like that on my time I'm never
like that with my friends
yeah and you were so adamant about that
yeah but after that fight you realize oh
maybe I am a little yeah little much
there's so many different emotion
different side of me that I didn't know
until I met you because you have been
like the craziest guy I've ever met and
it's been
together for pretty much queasy you are
crazy do you remember that first date we
had when we were on way to LACMA was it
yeah well I don't remember oh you're
talking about the time where I almost
[ __ ] that guy yeah and I barely knew you
and I thought I was gonna get into a car
accident you turn into this whole
different Sacramento guy we're using a
language that I swear it's English but I
don't understand what he's saying and
thank God your mom was there oh yes
basically we talked about that on I
think the first time she was on the
podcast yeah oh yeah yeah
and so basically he went bizarre and
turned into a Hulk and our one of our
first dates and I didn't know what to do
I was very quiet because I was freaked
the hell out and luckily his mom was on
the phone the whole time and then II
kind of I kind of learned how to how she
calmed him down yeah but that said like
usually if that was the case I'd be like
peace out but I didn't normally there
are a lot of the times where he turned
into a Hulk but at the same time it's
not I mean it's not like 50% of the time
is my fault too like I didn't know how I
would react or how I was handling the
situation could have done it much better
but yeah through that I learned you know
she's actually the first person that was
with that not I wouldn't say the first
person but usually like when I say hey I
need some space that usually just give
me space you know or they just not try
to make me mad and I was like why isn't
this working
like I'm asked I'm giving us a solution
let me walk away let me breathe and I'll
come back more level-headed and it's
just she wouldn't do it I'm like yo I'm
losing cuz I'm not gonna I didn't want
to leave her and so the only thing I did
I reverted back to this child just just
just you know get the [ __ ] away from me
you know like I'm just angry mm-hmm and
she didn't get it and then she you know
she doesn't like violence and it's not
like I got ever got violent with her
I've never gotten violent with her but I
mean violence in terms of like anger
loud anger you know we had a lot of
conversations on that of what cannot be
done after yeah after being in like
screaming and yelling she hates all that
[ __ ] and then you know and I once again
I grew up in a household where you know
my parents I've seen
fight super super hard I seem to get
physical mm-hmm I wouldn't say that
physical but I see my dad break [ __ ] I
see our parents generation that that was
kind of the normal thing yeah
so I I mean I'm not I'm not gonna say
that I haven't seen that either but no
definitely didn't like it yeah and I
like I said you know but also too you
know I mean we could talk about this on
another podcast it'll go on for another
hour well I got therapy yeah at the end
of the day like we we had to learn how
to kind of read each other better it's
like when goo and David says like don't
just let him breathe let him breathe a
little bit let him let him get angry let
him be upset and then talk about it when
you're when you're level-headed so when
he says that he's upset and he's angry
and he asked for space give him that
space because he's asking for it and
then you're telling me that's true no
you always do you always do it don't you
always do it it's not you never do it
now yeah and then for me I have to learn
how to like when I get to that very
angry space I can't scream I can't you
know break [ __ ] like that's like my
thing and I remember when I first broke
stuff from her she goes like she got
really scared and I was like why why are
you scared I'm I said I would never hit
a woman in my life I've never hit
anybody that I cared about she was not
about I'm not scared that you're gonna
hit me it just scares me I mean it
scares like seeing seeing that type of
[ __ ] and - what for what's normal to me
is it normal to everybody else no this
is how we would usually cope with our
anger you know that's why my hands
busted like it's [ __ ] I don't deal
with violence well like I mean I'm not
gonna say that I wasn't violent myself
like when I was younger like oh I've
heard stories from Becky being physical
I mean I used to love boxing for a
reason I used to love it no I'm not such
a fan of it just oh you did it thought
on a white not because I loved it then
it has so much anger that like boxing
was a way for me to like get the stress
out we should hit pads again but seeing
how you could be so violent with
inanimate objects and it freaks me out
because it's not that you're doing it to
me but then there's a side effect to it
there is this you know being scared and
trauma yeah it's traumatizing and so
when that happened I let him know after
it's weird cuz like when I see people do
that and they start breaking [ __ ] it
doesn't scare me it doesn't traumatize
me so that kind of took it as that like
if I see a guy like I know
guy right now who exerts pranking [ __ ]
I'm like you look like a dumb little
[ __ ] you know like so me it doesn't
even make me upset it's more like you
thought Angela the child yeah exactly
it doesn't resolve anything you only
built more anxiety if anything else so
after that we had the conversation of
that it's not gonna happen anymore if it
does you know we have certain things
that are on the list words like like
deal-breakers [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah well
that was a very productive podcast Hey
we got through it baby
oh man that was kind of nerve-racking
well we got we got a lot of a lot more
stuff to talk about and this is just one
podcast of many so case you're gonna be
my next podcast buddy for the next
couple of probably in the next month or
so so hope they don't get annoyed by me
oh they won't this is this is you guys
are hearing the real [ __ ] right now
this is real couple stuff the real story
yeah well you guys can catch the genius
brain podcast on all platforms Spotify
iTunes all that other good stuff you can
follow a little Mariel at Mariel
underscore underscore song on Instagram
and you can follow me at Davis o comedy
and genius brain everything else well
guys we will see you guys next time make
sure you stay well genius brain is a
podcast for anybody who needs a
conversation to follow them through
their their good old week stay safe
everyone
yeah a home exactly oh by the way before
we end this podcast I know sometimes
when she's talking I kind of like joke
around and I jab in between while she's
talking that's just me joking around I
like listening to her speak she's the
best I love you
sure say it - yeah he's he's joking guys
say I love you not that uh you know that
oh I love you say it to me why do I have
to say it is my feelings okay
no I want you to wait here chinga oh
yeah nah that's holding
[Laughter]
I'm gonna buy Solomon look at Ali I'm
telling her please hurry up and say you
say you love me this is disgusting it's
not making me want to say it it's okay
oh good your pardon sire
I'm good oh I need you
no no I shouldn't say laughter bye